[Musique]
c'est l'étoile montante du parti
démocrate
il appelle 38 ans il n'a été que le
maire d'une ville de cent mille
habitants
et pourtant pitbull adjedj figurent
parmi les favoris de la course
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il se présente comme l'anti tu as cette
hausse modérée
un homosexuel déclaré rafiq de campagne
climat et propose à tous une assurance
santé mais sans l'imposer
c'est aussi un fervent chrétien et gaza
mais ceux qui soutiennent pitbull adjedj
dit surtout de lui que c'est un surdoué
un vétéran de l'afghanistan un
polyglotte qui parle huilant l'espagnol
italien l'arabe le norvégien trond
sommes contents que ça va mieux mais
c'est en français qu'il nous dit
souhaité rétablir une meilleure relation
avec le canada important ici dans notre
avec nous ont des relations beaucoup
d'américains l'ont découvert lors des
débats télévisés les à south bend la
ville d' indiana qu'il a administré
pendant huit ans qu'il monde le connaît
et le surnomme affectueusement meilleur
pid
merci à
mais ce bad
peu de gens reconnaissent meilleur pitt
aussi bien que bouteflika une amie
d'enfance
le plus jeune candidat démocrate est
aussi musicien et il fait des concerts
avec elle chaque fois qu'il en a
l'occasion
c'est donc sans surprise qu'elle le
soutient qui
fort du soutien local c'est dans sa
ville sur les bords de la rivière saint
joseph que pitbull adjedj installer son
quartier de campagne j'aimerais mieux
les bénévoles s'y succèdent pour
contacter les électeurs des premiers
états à voter et pour vanter les mérites
de meilleur public s'est porté
volontaire elle aussi
les nombreuses grues qui surplombe la
ville témoigne de sa nouvelle vitalité
le centre de south bend est aujourd'hui
un gigantesque chantier de construction
mais pittsburgh et james ne bénéficient
pas de soutien de tous les habitants de
sa ville ses relations avec les
communautés noires et latino américaines
ont toujours été difficiles
beaucoup ici ont l'impression d'être
laissés pour compte car d'autres coins
de la ville présente un tout autre
visage le sud est est un quartier noir
les rues ici ne sont qu'un alignement de
tours si cela ne fait aucun doute
pitbull adjedj et le candidat des blancs
et des fortunés
un point de vue largement partagé ici
davis un ancien élu municipal a
travaillé pendant des années avec meyer
pitt et pourtant il ne votera pas pour
lui il met en cause sa gestion de la
police municipale trop blanche à ses
yeux pour une ville qui compte 40 %
minorité mais plus largement il met en
cause son manque d'expérience alors
comme beaucoup de noirs dans le pays
enlevez davis soutiendra l'ancien vice
président joe biden
depuis des mois pitbull hadjadj
multiplie les rassemblements dans les
premiers et a voté comme ici à des
moines en iowa
[Applaudissements]
il y parle de diversité
il vante son plan de lutte contre le
racisme de lutte contre la pauvreté sont
venus l'écouter sont à peu près tous
blancs
[Applaudissements]
et presque chacune de ses apparitions
est marquée par une manifestation de
militants noirs du groupe
la classe malheur sans l'appui des
minorités difficile de l'imaginer et
gagner moins
cette fois ci car ceux qui le
soutiennent en sont convaincus on n'a
pas fini d'entendre parler de budget
l'homme est jeune il a du talent
[Musique]
l'ambition et contrairement à la plupart
des autres candidats démocrates il a
tout son temps
[Musique]
nos mines